Daenerys is our only chance well there's
another
kill him
he turned them all
holy crap everybody we got to freak out
about Episode six so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet everybody poor went out for Viserion
let's hope that brands able to warg an
undead dragon and can somehow turn that
against the night king but we can mole
that over as we go through the video
this is really meant to be like their
big north of the wall episode even
though they had to deal with a couple of
their plot lines like the stuff
happening at Winterfell there were a
couple of good arya moments I feel like
they're foreshadowing some really
interesting stuff for her character but
let's just get into it so top 10 WTF and
book Easter eggs so number 10 everybody
marching north of the wall I love the
way they opened it too with the map
table pushing north as they cut to them
actually walking in the north they do a
good job with transitions this season
you may be really upset about how
they're doing the gross-out transitions
in earlier episodes with all that
literal crap and puss this was a little
more straight out there wasn't that much
comedy in it but they actually had a lot
of funny jokes back and forth as they
were talking to each other about their
backstories sort of referencing things
that have happened in the past there was
even a lot of earlier dialog that was
given to new characters like tormund
brings back up Sheila the bear so the
whole funny moment about Gendry just
wondering how do you keep warm north of
the wall tormund's advice totally legit
walking's good Fighting's better
best when he says you make do
with what you got he's talking about the
bear that he claims to have had
sheila the bear so torment was great in
this episode and actually after all
these scenes that he had these great
character moments and that nod he had
with the Hound at the end it makes me
feel like they're going to keep him around
for as long as possible and I'm totally
fine with that because currently as of
the end of the episode he's Manning
Eastwatch so I do think that that's
where the night king is going to try and
break through the wall so a bunch of
them are going to die there but I think
those will mostly be red shirt so
crossing my fingers for torment but the
other really cool mance rayder line that
torment had you may have remembered is
is how many people had to die for his
pride that was something that was said
to mance rayder way back during season
four around Watchers on the wall that
big battle how many of these people have
to die for your pride because at the
time he refused to bend the knee in the
same way that Jon Snow is doing the
exact same thing with Daenerys refusing
to bend the knee so in addition to all
that good fortune in the wars
to come talk people were like oh my god
does this mean that John snows going to
die because every character that has
said that has then gone on to a swift
death shortly thereafter so I was kind
of disappointed with the amount of
people they did not get rid of in this episode
but there was a lot of mirroring for the
Battle of the bastards episode where Jon
Snow pushes up through the body so he's
sort of like coming back to life
so metaphorically Jon Snow is dying but
not literally dying love tormund's lying
about gingers with the Hound just trying
to work his blood up a little bit
we're both kissed by fire just like your
face there and he sort of tells him
about what happened to him without
directly referencing the mountain so
hopefully we'll follow up with that in
episode 7 I'm not expecting legit
cleganebowl but they will both be in
proximity to each other next week
Jon Snow and Joris conversation was
really good he tries to give him long
cloth but remorseful for the things that
he's done says you know you need to keep
this may it bring you good fortune it
also references children that he might
have so he hasn't been with Ygritte in a
long time now he's with Daenerys but a
lot of people are like wait a minute
Daenerys isn't supposed to be able to
have children anymore at least that's
what she believes she also says later in
the episode the dragons are her children
she'll never have any more and she's so
sad because one of them has died there
was the Tyrion line where he talks about
the succession so that's a bit of a meta
commentary on Jon Snow being officially
in the line of succession but also what
comes next after them like potential
children that they might have so it's
just Game of Thrones planting seeds for
the idea that they'll probably going to
have a child at some point during season
eight or she'll be pregnant it just
depends on how much time passes remember
nine months sir she's supposed to be
pregnant now but we don't know how long
she's been pregnant so don't get too
worked up over the timeline they're just
setting the stage for Daenerys to
probably get pregnant with Jon Snow's
child sometime next year we can talk a
little bit more about that later this
week that's probably worth the bonus
video just because there's so much
backstory about why Daenerys is supposed
to be barren right now in the prophecy
about her getting pregnant again in her
womb quickening so number nine Arya and
Sansa the Winterfell plot this was not
my most favorite moment especially their
early scenes to
I feel like the bag of faces and then
playing the game of faces was probably
their best scene together but because
Winterfell is a big location you have
brand there's a lot of Mythology
happening there you also have to service
this storyline so I am totally not down
for this manufactured conflict between
the two of them Arya is mad at Sansa
because she believes that sonses a
traitor to their family but almost
everybody else that was part of that
situation and knew about the letter like
maester Luwin understands that Sansa was
forced to write the letter and didn't
mean what she said the problem with this
scene is that Arya is supposed to have
this superhuman ability to detect when
people are lying and she can't tell that
Sansa is not lying when she says that
the words of the letter are false like
she's like I didn't mean that but Arya
still believes that she's a traitor so a
giant thumbs-down for that but it
remains to be seen what it is that
brings them together remember the lone
wolf dies but the pack survives so
something is going to have to bring them
together in Littlefinger's trying to
engineer a situation where Sansa is
completely dependent upon him for
political advice and how to deal with
the other northern Lords because science
is worried that now that Jon Snow has
been gone for so long that they'll all
just bolt but number 8 Tyrion trying to
get Daenerys to chill out because they
have this big meeting coming with Cersei
don't do anything rash please don't burn
everything to the ground he does give
her that little out like if they
actually do try to hurt you then we
burned them to the ground
but like I said he references the world
that they're trying to create what comes
next and then Daenerys gets really upset
at the idea of the succession we'll talk
about that after the war is won so like
I said just a nod to Jon Snow also being
part of the succession in her not really
sure what's going to happen between the
two of them like she probably hasn't
totally figured out what she's going to
do after she actually sits on the Iron
Throne she's so worried about the war
right now it just planting more seeds
for potential baby between the two of
them so we'll see how that plays out but
number seven fighting the giant white
polar bear flaming polar bear triggering
the Hound that was actually a good
moment so anything on fire will trigger
the Hound but I wouldn't get too down on
him because that is a giant bear so even
if it weren't flaming that anybody would
probably flip their but the meta
thing
going on here - is that torment had just
gotten done talking about doing what you
needed to do to keep warm like doing it,
the joke about him having
Sheila the bear up north of the wall and
then cut to an actual white polar bear
so I feel like that's the show's way of
sort of meta referencing a bunch of
previous things that they've done on the
show so the bear is more of like a funny
WTF twist like oh this is a giant bear
Oh looks like giant animals can be
turned into bites - so it's also
foreshadowing for vissarion being turned
at the end of the episode number six the
small group of whites in the single
white Walker just serves as an explainer
for you end the creator the creations
fall as well so it just set up for the
end of the episode where they're like
get him he created them all so they
have the idea now now they just need
another terrible Tyrian plan so I mean
we can make jokes about how terrible
everyone's plans have been this season
but at least the seed has been planted
now they get a white Walker and maybe
take down a squadron of whites but they
get the night king and the entire army
will fall instantly so that just feels
like a big season 8 moment where
somebody sacrifices their life to take
him down with either say like Arya's
Valyrian dagger or some really special
weapon but in doing so giving up their
life they get him it in the war so we
can theory craft about that after the
season is over because there's still a
whole bunch of stuff left to happen in
episode 7 but they send Gendry running
back he is one of the fastest runners
I've ever seen but I'll talk a little
bit about the timeline of the episode
because as they run for the island in
the middle of the frozen lake they were
standing there in the episode for more
than a single day because you see the
Sun go down as Gendry reaches the wall
and then it goes from being really dark
to them sort of waking up with it being
light so it just lets you know that they
were sitting on that island for a day
maybe a little bit more than that so it
does kind of explain how they're able to
get a raven to Daenerys and she makes it
all the way back by the end of the
episode but at number 5 the Hound just
gets really pissed off and starts
throwing rocks misses one the whites
seem intelligent enough to put two and
two together so we can talk about that
later too because it's like if they can
understand this then how intelligent are
they are they just mindless creatures
that are filled by the will of the why
walkers that created them but it's on
and they start to fight them off but you
get this sense it's very battle of the
bastards esque where they get surrounded
just like Jon Snow's group was during
that episode and I love this wide shot
because it's just like the sea of ants
washing over them until Daenerys
preceded by Jets of flame comes to save
them so like I said battle the bastards
it's a very Knights of the Vale twist
type moment like oh you think all is
lost even though we know that Jon Snow
is probably not going to die
so we can argue in the comments about
which battle this season featuring
dragons was the best like Daenerys
versus Jaime or Daenerys versus the army
of the Dead
I feel like this moment is actually
meant to be more meaningful for the
characters in the other Jamie episode is
meant to be like a bigger action set
piece so I do think you know if you're
just talking about spectacle then the
Jamie episode is probably better but
this episode with Viserion dying is way
more gut-wrenching so number four back
to Winterfell
Sansa upset about the northern Lords
potentially leaving Fiennes Arya's bag
of faces in Arya makes like she's going
to get her and wear her face I feel
like that's the whole point of the scene
they want to make you wonder about that
even though I think that's complete
garbage there's no way that Arya is
going to get Sansa but I did like the
way they brought back the game of faces
in the sheer fact that there is a
literal bag of faces that they
introduced in the episode is probably a
hat tip to Aria continuing to wear
different faces in season 8 so we can
all wonder in theory craft about whose
faces she'll wear I would love for her
to get Littlefinger in the finale
potentially and then wear his face
through Season eight that would be a
great way to keep Aiden Gillen around
because he's a great actor just they
haven't been doing a lot of really
interesting stuff with his character
this season but Arya wearing his face
that would be a lot of fun and of course
back to the big battle number three the
night king javelins Viserion down who
dies sinks to the bottom of the lake
everybody's freaking out Jon Snow also
goes down trying to help them get away
so after benjin sacrifices himself to
allow him to get away just almost a
throwaway moment and how quick it is
like where's benjin been has he been
watching the Battle of this whole time
either way I think it's the show's way
of telling us that hey this is our last
Benjen moment he's not coming back after
this
but number
two on the boat back Daenerys sees Jon
Snow's scars and just I think it
crystallizes her opinion of him in how
he's willing to sacrifice himself for
his people his level of commitment they
share a very tender moment she talks
about her dead children I'll never have
another he officially bends the knee
even though he's still lying in bed and
then she sort of takes off to leave him
to recover it gets a little awkward
between the two of them but they just
want to let you know that yes there's a
thing happening between them here and
then of course number one we have to
talk about the night king raising
vissarion as his undead mount it's going
to be great there's so many questions
that I've seen about this one where did
he get those chains from - we'll
Viserion now that he's undead with the
blue eye will he breathe blue fire and
three can bran warg a dragon who is also
undead my initial take away on the
chains is that those are taken from
hardhome they're just big boat chains
used to drag ships out of the water so
that's probably where they came from and
it would be really cool to see viscera
and breathe blue fire it'd be a really
easy way to differentiate him visually
on-screen when all the dragons are
fighting each other in the air during
season eight which i think is
mutually-assured at this point the three
heads of the Dragon one of them will be
the night king now it as for a brand
warding a dragon I do think it's
possible I think he's getting powerful
enough to do that but I think the best
we can hope for right now is just that
bran is able to somehow mess with the
night Kings connection with Vissarion so
during a battle he's able to distract
him so that John and Daenerys riding the
other dragons can somehow take him down
so mission one now is getting the night
king back on the ground and in order to
do that you have to take down undead
Vissarion but let me know in the
comments what did you guys think of the
episode I feel like there were a bunch
of mythology twists and I do like the
idea of an undead dragon a lot of great
ideas even though their plan was
absolute crap like John's like I'm so
sorry about this we should have never
gone yes that is correct you should have
never gone there's much easier ways to
convince Cersei about a white Walker
they probably would have been better off
taking Thoreau's south of the wall and
using him as the example that whites
exist like look here this is a person
that you probably met in King's Landing
Cersei he is now undead and running
trying to bite everyone's hands off and
I actually almost another book Easter
egg is when the hound says barek you
better be careful you're on your last
life in the books he's on his sixth life
Thoros goes down so he has to use his
life to give life to Lady Stoneheart he
gives her the kiss of life so me and a
lot of other people were wondering if he
was going to do that for Jon Snow but
obviously they opted not to kill anybody
except for Thoros in the episode so I
feel like that's probably going to be one
of the biggest complaints like now is
the time where it is okay to start
getting rid of your main characters we're in
the final episodes but I'll post my
finale trailer video next then new Rick
and Morty I'll say congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Rhys Clark
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here to learn
about Rhaegar Targaryen and you can
click here for my episode 5 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight